Russia has dismissed the accusations of
the team investigating the downing of
malaysia airlines flight mh17 as quote
absolutely baseless earlier on Wednesday
investigators charged four suspects with
murder over their alleged involvement in
the 2014 tragedy which claimed 298 lives
among the suspects are three Russians
and a Ukrainian the joint investigation
team have also now requested cooperation
from Russia after showing Moscow's
numerous offers to assist over the past
five years
let's now bring in Igor sadhana off to
the program eager has been tracking this
not just today I should add for quite
some time but today is the point that
the joint investigation team Igor
actually named names what's been said
well exactly it's not just names it's
been photographs it's been some
wiretapped phone calls but I mean the
authenticity of those phone calls were
really subject to very very the
verification is up to the court is what
I'm saying to the official court of law
we've seen a lot of accusations and the
investigation has said that these four
people were likely very likely not the
ones who pushed the button that sent the
missile flying up and do you know Downey
the mh17 but they have said that they
maybe even gave direct orders that they
facilitated that the investigation
believes they facilitated the smuggling
of the buk missile launch system from
Russia into Ukraine and that eventually
basically that they their hands are mod
with this heinous crime of downing this
jet as you said three Russians one
Ukrainian interestingly enough none of
them have connections to a Russian to a
Russian military base to a Russian
military brigade that is accused by the
same investigation of smuggling the said
buk missile launch system that down the
jet still these people are they the
investigators are saying that there will
be putting out that they will be putting
their names on the international
most-wanted list that they will be
charging them with this with this crime
that they will
that they are set to take that they want
to take this case into the court of law
or they they said that the best way they
believe is to do it is to use is to stay
in the Netherlands and to use the Dutch
legal system and to try them in the
hague speaking of people who were
mentioned probably the most high-profile
of them at the time of the tragedy he
was the Minister of Defence of the
breakaway Donetsk People's Republic now
of course unrecognized you know
self-proclaimed also at the same time
they're saying that they will not be
asking Russia to extradite them to the
Netherlands because they simply believe
that because there's no agreement
between Russia and the EU an extradition
agreement what I mean to say but they
will be asking Russia's law enforcement
Russia's Security Service to bring to
find these suspects themselves and bring
them into questioning to question them
for the Dutch led investigation and in
terms of the probe itself figure it's
not just Russia that's been quite
critical quite a significant player as
well well indeed because all of this all
of this happened all these these
announcements happened with Russia
absent on the board Russia wasn't
invited Russia was kind of ostracized
and kept away from the whole
investigation and I mean Russia even had
to bang on many doors to try and to get
at least some information that it had to
the investigation but no as you've
mentioned Russia is not the only one
critical for instance even Malaysia that
is on board Malaysia is the country is a
direct victim country is also many
people exactly it was their airline so
even then while officially the are on
board we did see a representative on
Malaysia sitting behind that table and
you know delivering even some of his
remarks but previously we've heard the
most high-profile people in the
Malaysian government criticizing the
probe and calling it politicized Ovilus
they are accusing Russians of firing the
missile but what is the evidence it
could even be the Ukrainian government
because they too have the same missile
we don't know why we are a screwed
from the examination but from the very
beginning we see too much politics in it
the idea was not to find out how this
happened and all that but they seem to
be concentrated on trying to pin it on
Russia here we have parties who have
some political interests in the matter
and they examine so too much politics
the man is saying why is that it could
be because again Russia had a lot of
information to provide to the joint
investigative team but they decided
either not to use it or not to believe
it now we've created a short clip that
explains that in detail because it may
seem a bit overwhelming so here's just a
recap of major points that rush of major
facts that Russia tried to provide to
the Dutch led investigation the previous
G IT investigations so many triumphantly
shouting accusations at Russia but
instead of trying to out yell its
critics Russia showed original documents
raw data and experiment results which
poked holes in the investigation Exhibit
A Russia's Defense Ministry dug into its
archives and deep it traced the missile
based on the pieces discovered among the
debris of mh17 the Ministry determined
its tail number revealing the full life
cycle of the project tile manufactured
back in the days of the Soviet Union in
1986 the missile was shipped to a
military base in Ukraine it never left
the territory of the Soviet republic and
then after the breakup of USSR of the
country according to the ministry's data
the buk missile was moved only within
the borders of Ukraine and in 2014 it
was set up and stored at a base in the
west of the country Exhibit B
[Music]
the manufacturer of book mrs. Alma Sante
conducted a field experiments of its own
it targeted a segment of an aircraft
hull similar to the downed Boeing with
book missiles the goal was to determine
the likely angle from which the
projectile impacted on the Malaysian
aircraft back in 2014 and
consequentially pinpoint the likely spot
on the ground from which the shot was
fired the verdict it could have only
been launched from the Ukraine
controlled part of the frontline exhibit
see Russia provided plenty of technical
results to the dutch LED investigation
from the specs of the buk missile two
radar readings from southern Russia
which borders with East Ukraine
according to Moscow they can't be forged
and on that day raiders failed to detect
any launch which would be impossible if
indeed a buk missile had been fired from
a rebel controlled area so as you laid
out their information findings were
given from Russia to the JIT what was
done with that information well
interestingly enough you've just you've
all just seen what sort of information
Russia has provided but repeatedly
repeatedly during this media conference
the representatives of the joint
investigation team they they were saying
something says stuff like Russia did not
crepe cooperate at all Russia did not
explain anything that Russia didn't
provide any information despite despite
all this but eventually they were kind
of forced into admitting that they did
have a look at this information but they
chose to trust other facts over over
what Russia presented to them that's
laughing and if you look back you can
establish that from the first day after
the 17th of July the Russian Federation
hasn't disclosed anything about what
happened and that is a slap in the face
to all the relatives of the victims and
I call on them to start cooperating to
tell us what happened yeah we've
received that from a
from the Russian Federation the
information about the missile and the
documents about the missile and we also
received the radar data and that wasn't
clear enough to say exactly what was
happened with the missile and that given
this doesn't didn't give us the right
picture so they were so adamant at first
saying that they did not receive any
information but then only presented with
a question over how they ruled out the
version that Ukraine's that the missile
belonged to Ukraine they kinda were
forced to admit that there yeah they did
look at it but look at them even at the
radar at Russia's radar readings
probably but they chose to believe the
radar readings presented by Ukraine also
a biased site and this in this whole
investigation has their yeah you were
saying yeah just on the actual reaction
yes the Russian we're looking at we've
just been looking at a quote by the
Russian officials what what's it being
just sum up what that's actually yeah
sure because we've just in the within
the past hour we heard from the Russian
Foreign Ministry and basically they've
called that a groundless the groundless
accusations and they said so because
they've accused the joint investigative
team of using data that came from
questionable sources and they also the
Russian Foreign Ministry also pointed
out that all the accusations coming from
the Dutch led investigators that Russia
did not do enough to cooperate with the
investigation well again underlining
that well look there's this much
information that we've given to you and
you still say that we're not cooperating
enough and I mean even Vladimir Putin
before beforehand he had said that if
Russia is made part of the investigation
then Russia would be happy to recognize
its conclusions but all of all of that
hasn't been done
you